había sido convocado desde Washington
donde asistía las reuniones del fmi Poco
después de llegar a Londres Se quedó sin
trabajo el exministro de Hacienda
confirmó en su carta de dimisión que se
le había pedido que diera un paso al
costado asumiendo la culpa por un
desastroso mini presupuesto en el que su
jefa listras había basado su campaña de
Liderazgo del partido conservador la
primera ministra se reunió con la prensa
el viernes y dijo que había tomado una
decisión difícil disfraz repitió su
mantra del crecimiento y nombró al
sucesor de quarteng le pedía Jeremy será
el nuevo ministro de finanzas es uno de
los ministros y parlamentarios más
experimentados y respetados del gobierno
y comparte mis convicciones y ambiciones
para nuestro país presentar a su plan
fiscal a medio plazo a finales de este
mes el mini presupuesto del mes pasado
Que coincidía recortes Fiscales a la
rentas altas Pero que apenas financiaba
la medida hizo que la libra cayera en
picado posteriormente el gobierno se
retrató de esos recortes Fiscales y el
de un nuevo giro de 80 grados archivando
un recorte del impuesto de sociedades la
primera ministra se negó a responder
algunas preguntas de los periodistas y
cuando se le entregó si se disculparía
con el partido conservador eludió la
pregunta y acortó la rueda de prensa con
la libra esterlina cayendo un 1% frente
al dólar en el transcurso del día y los
llamamientos desde dentro de su partido
para que dimita lista se está quedando
rápidamente sin margen de maniobra